hello and welcome to this video playing
baritone g35 84 okay now if I it looks
like the normal reply mean talk about
strange opening play where it is moving
the bishop all over the place yeah the
question is can you refute it directly
or is it just bad and probably it is
just bad and not refutable directly
queenie tour ever looks again like a
strange move running into a 90 64 okay
okay so now just this 494 I guess okay
um yeah in four it says something better
it should be for f3 and that's probably
it is good
I know it is best but it is good castles
Bishop g4 it's pretty awful and this one
now you will probably play deform
and I wonder if they are probably a
couple of things that are good but maybe
this is this is relatively clean
threatening Naga 3 NID 3 and then I get
to get 3 I mean how is he getting ever
getting something moved here on the
queenside
so before stuff maybe not clear what was
best damn seems like he's preparing f3
yeah this I probably just take 195 is
also a strong move going for me going
for the the direct fork I took the same
let's do it way that's very simple
threat and he will certainly see it but
there were the left quite quite good so
yeah take it or not
try to play a3 of course I came with to
take this get this out just try to play
in a way that the bishop won't see one
never moves
it is never able to move it I should win
doesn't really look like he is going to
I mean I thought f3 was completely
mandatory completely mandatory to fight
against the e4 pawn so this looks like
it should win pretty pretty quickly
actually
[Music]
check see what you're gone now can gauge
226 check check okay so where's the mate
play Bailey's okay I don't need to find
it where instamate loopy sexy I wanted
to do hooky five but they both should
work yet that opening was a real real
disaster and I actually think this is
already a bit turkey after d5 you don't
really have a great reply the same as e
45 G 3 had it doesn't relieve it doesn't
work I mean you can do something like
this
which is yeah which is just
uncomfortable but probably is still kind
of okay but I don't like this but maybe
it's if you now now start to play good
moves that could prove it this is
running into her the Tempe and it's
really really really terrible the engine
wants to play rook e8 namely and I try
to play in a simple way and I hope I
succeeded I think it always was a big
edge here the f1 really surprised me
because I think I mean I understand that
every year smaller move that probably
works but if you cannot you have to try
at least to play somewhere three-year
otherwise you're pretty much
this is losing strategic aim if I get to
yeah I get to keep keep this protected
and I just attack him yeah yeah but the
thing to take from it that's not a good
opening thanks for watching